good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday happy
disgrace Queen day happy June 30th happy
everything day what an amazing day to be
alive
it's disgrace Queen Day dqj not to be
confused with Dairy Queen Day which is
also my favorite day I think that in
honor of DQ day we should all head to DQ
get a blizzard watch disgrace Queen
available now to stream we're streaming
services are I absolutely love that idea
like I know you're not serious but I am
about the Dairy Queen I thought I could
so go for a blizzard so my special came
out last night at midnight if you
pre-ordered it on iTunes it
automatically downloaded it and I
watched it on my Apple TV and it was
just I can't explain what it's like to
see yourself on TV
it's everything of the sort and I also
like was I worked so hard I'm like my
glam and my snatch this for that day and
I'm like so proud of the payoff because
I watch it and like of course my double
chin like bothers me a little bit but
like I'm really pleased with the way
that I look which doesn't always happen
for me so that's literally all I care
about
I've watched a special so many times I
watched it again last night and I'm just
loving everyone tagging me in it thank
you guys so much for watching it thank
you guys so much for purchasing it I
really really appreciate it I'm like so
proud of it like I have a comedy special
[ __ ] bye it's so exciting I haven't
watched it yet I'm saving it maybe
tonight maybe this weekend we'll see I
mean it's just so sad I had all these
plans like for what I was gonna do for
the release I wanted to rent out a movie
theater I pick and like invite literally
everyone and their mothers but that
unfortunately didn't happen for me even
though I'm not that upset about it
because I had the hardest time staying
up till midnight last night I did such a
bad migraine literally like in my
eyebrow it was all day so I'm annoying
and all I wanted to do was go to sleep
to make it go away but I couldn't um and
I was like a yawning falling asleep I
did a live at 12 to like celebrate it
was literally the most boring life I was
so tired but now I'm like this I've
slept eight hours and I'm reinvigorated
with a disgrace Queen Spirit and nobody
can stop me
reinvigorated with the disgraced Queen
spirit also I'm wearing my disgraced
Queen merch which is available at shop
morning toast calm in sizes like small
through 3xl so there's tons of sizing
options available I'm wearing an XL
honestly it's a little oversized I think
I could also wear a large but you know
me I'm an oversized Queen in addition to
being a disgraced Queen
exactly um in addition to just shelling
the [ __ ] out of my special we have a
fabulous show and some construction
behind us oh my god feel free to
Construction has resumed in phase one in
New York and like people the
construction companies are going wild
construction is out to play everywhere
you go in the city not just in our
studio in our ear there is construction
happening it is so loud and so noisy but
you know what like it means life is
being breathed back in New York but that
was really crazy I thought they were
gonna come here to the window
unfortunately like we are literally next
to a construction site like some people
like you know they fix potholes there's
you know a little bump in the road some
some scaling a building window-washing
know there's a full-blown building being
built next to us that's gonna be like a
four year project right now in the
building next to us there is level it's
al it's a lot it's a lot so it'll it'll
be exciting to watch them progress over
time yeah any people moving there after
they're done yes so we now we do have a
sound track of the construction sounds
and it's because if you're listening to
the show and some we're not New York you
can feel like you're in New York that's
a movie that's what's so amazing about
the morning toast aside from being
Premium Morning Show giving you all your
news that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite of your morning
toast it is also kind of like a
transporter you know you feel like
you're in New York you almost smell it
you hear the sirens in the construction
you could smell the dog [ __ ] on the
street it's really an interns formative
experience it's an interactive
experience so you know what I don't
think many other podcasts can offer you
that kind of quality that's what I'm
saying I don't think so either so here
we are ready to do that oh also we've
been working on our audio because we saw
that people were having an issue with
one ear bud working the other one not so
hopefully it's fixed today if it's not
let us know that we are striving towards
getting that right for you so keep us
posted but we tried something different
today yes and it's fabulous so let us
know if you know here let me do a little
audio test pre-order my comedy special
when that pre-order [ __ ] oh my god I got
so used to that order my comedy special
disgraced Queen on iTunes it's also
available on Amazon and a couple other
places that I keep forgetting to
remember but something about DISH
Network I'll post all the detail
my Instagram well it's just like we were
saying last week if you have an Apple TV
you can just use the overall search
which is just an incredible feature that
changes the game
it's an incredible feature and speaking
of TV in our TV recaps Eggman I'm dying
to talk about athlete a which is the
Larry Nasser documentary that I just
have so many thoughts on so we will do
that at the end of the document at the
end of the episode so many people were
asking me to recap it and I didn't know
what it was about cuz athlete egg
doesn't exactly scream like Larry Nasser
um but I stumbled upon it on Netflix and
it was very good and I have many
thoughts can't wait to hear I didn't
watch anything yesterday because I was
reading for the redheads are Maya
Angelou book I Know Why the Caged Bird
Sings I literally read it all day
yesterday I finished it last night um I
was like 1 a.m. because I just couldn't
put it down so I'm excited to talk about
that on the redheads but no I cannot
contribute to the TV recap when does the
redheads episode come out first Thursday
of every month so it's shopping on
Thursday right before you head out for
the holiday weekend fabulous
ok should we get right into it I used to
read stories actually I'm looking
forward to discussing the fast eye story
is that you need to know before you wake
up and take a bite out of your morning
toast fabulous let's do it we should
have a button fabulous oh my god wait we
also we need to record the Kelly's
mindless news bit and we also need to
record a fabulous bit ok let's add it to
the we've a soundboard here that's like
when you hear the crunch
we're very high-tech yeah it's it's
premium ok first story obviously the
news site dropped while we were
recording yesterday Kodi is paying two
hundred million dollars for 20% stake in
Kim Kardashian brand k'kaw cosmetics
giant Coty Inc is doubling down on its
investment in the kardashian-jenner clan
shares of the Big Apple company jumped
by more than 14 percent in early trading
on Monday after the announced plans to
sink two hundred million dollars into a
20% stake in Kim Kardashian's
four-year-old k'kaw makeup brand the
deal calls for Kody to develop new
products with Kardashian including
skincare hair and nail brands and
follows Kody sand follows Kody six
hundred million dollar investment last
year in the fledgling makeup company of
Kardashian's half-sister is it fledgling
is that a negative word fledgling is a
negative word right how dare they like
that sounds like struggling right let me
confirm that fledgling but it's
obviously not because if they're
deciding to invest in Kim that's like
Kylie's investment went well no no I
think it's fine
I think if flood chilling is a good word
I think it's a fine word a weird word
for the choice it's about a bird I don't
know um
makeup company of Kardashian's
half-sister Kylie Jenner wear it now
owns a majority stake so Kody bought
over 50% of Kylie for what six hundred
yes
so does this technically value Kim's at
less or more it values Kim at a billion
and now people are saying like she's the
real billionaire family because like
people are just continuing to pit these
sisters against each other I don't know
exactly what goes on in their home but I
do know that they are so happy for one
another they're not like comparing their
wallets I agree with that but I do think
part like a small very very small part
of Kim died a little bit when like her
sister Kylie just like waltzed in with a
billion dollar company after Kim like
has been breaking her back putting the
entire family on her back for the last
ten years
I don't think our competitive small part
of her diet I think she's been working
and doing all these deals for like ten
years and I think when Kylie did it it
said that like on the one hand yeah I
was frustrating she hit it out of the
gate on the first try but it said the
template for what the rest of them we're
gonna do in terms of direct-to-consumer
make up companies for sure but I'm just
saying I think I don't know that we
would even have k'kaw if it weren't for
Kylie cosmic I don't think that they're
competitive but I just think like with
the billionaire thing I think Kim cares
a little bit and like she just wanted to
have it you know her own um yeah well
now she's a billionaire and they're
saying Kylie's not a billionaire and I
just don't think either of them care
whether or not Forbes considers them a
billionaire no but I do think they care
whether I consider them a billionaire
and I do yeah oh they'll always be
billionaires in my heart to me it's just
like if you're rich you're a billionaire
like there's a certain level of wealth
it's like five hundred million or a
billion it really doesn't matter yeah
there's like those people a financial
people and like to the people who are
between 500 and billion like they just
want to get to that I think it's like
it's like the billionaire's Club you
know yeah it's a place to be Kanye
posted a very strange but lovely tribute
to Kim on his Twitter there was um some
pictures of fruit and I didn't
understand the whole fruit mentality
while you're laughing
why I'm not I'm not laughing what's
funny what did I miss nothing you're
both like staring at each other
did I see something bad with the fruit
no you literally gave me that look like
when I say something like bad no no I'm
sorry we can clear this up later like I
swear okay so he posted a picture of
fruit and like I didn't understand like
the whole fruit metaphor but it was
actually a lovely tweet even though some
people were calling it and sensitive
like giving given the current climate
like people are losing their jobs like
you're bragging about your wife becoming
a billionaire which I did agree with but
he's really proud of his wife and it was
so sweet he was like you've weathered so
many storms like nobody deserves this
more than you and it was really really
sweet we stand on me chef that's really
sweet he also has new music coming out
today again he announced like a new
album called God's country Blake Shelton
Blake Shelton coming out with the
trademark dispute yeah he's so weird
about his music in the sense that like
there's no like press or promo for it
like it just comes me I don't know I
think when Jesus's king was coming out
remember he was doing all of those
really long interview well he did
airplane karaoke yeah no he did Shh he
did like beats wine more than I would
like today we're coming it's like one
hour long economy interviews promoting
Jesus is king but then the album like
tuna come out it was delayed three times
yeah but then it came out yeah and then
we promoted it here on the morning test
it was a really great album also I think
what's so interesting about this deal is
just from a consumer perspective is that
they're gonna be expanding and take him
kardashian-west hair and nails you know
she does always have like nice hands and
nails yeah and she doesn't do like long
um
stiletto nails she's like very like mom
hands uh-huh
but you know what's so interesting when
you think about the cycle of the
Kardashian and like the evolution of
their businesses is that like where they
are now is actually really where they
started like they used to have that
Kardashian beauty hairstyle and all of
those brands that used to sell in like
Kmart and of course what they're doing
that was more elevated in a more
streamlined but they really have always
been doing this do a shape or form yeah
but that's why it's successful I think
everyone I don't think there's ever a
question like just Kylie where Kylie
cosmetics or disk in where k'kaw
disorder we're just Chloe we're good
Americans right and so that is what they
call
authentic authentic city you know we
know a lot about that here at the
morning trusting us how we are to
organic
podcast interviewers organic and
authentic we're yeah I gotta think I'm
so happy for Kim you know I just money
is always good you know it can't hurt
yeah
it can't hurt I really was like
wondering curious excited for when she
would hit that billion dollar valuation
and it's here and she works hard and
Congrats Congrats exactly honestly I
have a lot of AI in terms of like what I
thought was gonna make him a billionaire
I thought it was gonna be skins first
just because to me he's just churning
out say yes and right sales sales
droughts drops draw sellout sellout
sellout that's how much it's happening
ya know and I thought that was probably
gonna be her billion dollar company that
was gonna happen like just as fast as
Kylie cuz like when Kylie came out with
Kylie cosmetics it was just like you
knew it was right yeah and branding was
right the idea was right Kylie
everything was perfect and when Kay
McCain came out with k'kaw beauty I was
like yeah this is good but I didn't
think it was gonna be a billion dollar
company but the second skims launched
and we got the product and it was just
good and everyone was loving it like I
thought like that made sense that's
gonna be the billion dollar idea I still
think that it could be another billion
dollar idea and I hope that she keeps
working at it yes especially cuz I love
the stuff I think it's the place I order
from most during quarantine well now
they're moving into like not just
shapewear but like fujiyama's and I have
a set the pajamas are heavy
I have like the modal light grey pajamas
for like a few drops ago and they're
literally the most comfortable pajamas I
own I got those in cream they're the
most comfortable with Yamazaki always
looking for them on the site and I
couldn't find them but then she just did
the summer pajama drop and so I did get
a pair of pajamas from the summer pajama
drop summer pajamas are so important
I've been waking up with such [ __ ]
like sweat behind my neck even though I
sleep I have got a convert my air
conditioning in my apartment is
commercial like what you would use to
cool down at Duane Reade is what I have
in my house because the person who owns
my apartment like I guess is obsessed
with air conditioning and I'm not
complaining so I sleep in 59 degrees 59
degree air conditioning and I wake up
sweating is that normal no hmm and it's
not like I'm having night terrors or
anything I just wake up with like this
misty vibe on my skin yeah that happened
to me like a few nights in the last week
where I just like woke up with like neck
sweat right and when you blot your hair
and then you wake up with neck sweat
it's literally one of the most annoying
things ever yeah it is quite annoying
these are my problems I'm sorry
Claudia that's annoying
oh my god yes it is theatre comedy
special no order I know but it's more
fun to say preorder I know it sounds so
legit and it's also just like that's the
joke that we've made and we're gonna
continue on I'm so glad you agree okay
next story
someone is eclipsing Kelly's mindless
news ooh Ryan Seacrest and Shana Taylor
split for the third time though they
remain good friends like who in the hell
new Ryan Seacrest had a girlfriend I
feel like we all knew he had a
girlfriend no clue we ever since things
dissolved between him and one Julianne
Hough we just never put so much stock
into his next relationship to me the
last girl he dated is Julianne Hough and
I mean they're both single now so really
anything can happen but Ryan's secret
secret and his girlfriend Shane Oh
Taylor have split once again on Monday
representative for the longtime host
confirmed that the couple have gone
their separate ways um also concurrently
Seacrest is currently vacationing in
Mexico with friends and is newly dating
someone in that works yeah so he has a
new flame which makes me feel like this
breakup happened a while ago yeah um but
maybe someone got pictures of him with
someone else and they thought he was
cheating so he had to like explain that
he's no longer in a relationship and now
he's in a new one yeah this is PR 101
and very handled very well by his
representatives yeah I just have a
thought I he definitely used like the
same people that Kelly likes over at
People magazine yeah they were like
don't worry we got you we got Kelly's
like I got the girl just chill right let
me text her I'll put you all in a group
chat um when he comes to Ryan Seacrest
dating life for some reason I am
incapable of like seeing Ryan Seacrest
like have a game like the idea like
trying to imagine him like picking up a
girl like I just feel like it's not he's
not good at it no I just feel like he
thinks that being Ryan Seacrest is
enough right and he like goes on a date
and it's like hey it's me Ryan Seacrest
like I'm not gonna put forth any further
effort and take it or leave it do you
want to be dating Ryan Seacrest right
and that's where they go from there and
for most girls in Hollywood I think
that's tough ya know be enough for me
that would be that would be a really
great starting point yeah I feel like if
I were to ever you know date someone in
Hollywood
I'm very strategic like I'm not looking
to fall in love with a celebrity because
it's not realistic like they just they
they all move on so fast so I would
really be looking for more of like a
strategic business partner a strategic
partnership and Ryan Seacrest's would be
the perfect person for me to date like
he has so many ins in media in reality
TV and production and cable like he's
really like a business mogul in in my
industry and I would totally date him
for like yeah some roles or something
and some jobs for sure I think that that
would be a match made in heaven
ya know we're like we're the same height
and I'm a little like the problem with
dating someone short is that like I'm so
fat that like it's just it brings you
down you bring like the whole like we
would just look so weird together but
again I'd be getting all these new jobs
that I wouldn't really care I just look
stout like and he maybe he would look at
all I don't know I just I can't really
picture us together but I do feel as
though it's a match made in heaven yeah
assuming things don't work out between
him and Julian Oh actually things
already haven't worked out because he's
already in a new relationship right
alleged also like always in a
relationship that one yeah some guys you
know I respect that some guys just like
to be you know committed that's
beautiful Ryan that's beautiful
Ryan that's beautiful okay next up a
little entertainment news kwibi
is remaking The Princess Bride with Joe
Jonas and sophie turner oh my god I was
worried about to write this story off a
bit of a misleading oh but exciting
nonetheless Oh what's the real story
love 1987 film The Princess Bride is
getting a DIY makeover from some of
Hollywood's biggest names though the
project is helmed by Juno director Jason
Reitman who was previously staged live
readings of the film script the remake
was shot entirely at home by each cast
member using their phones beginning June
29th kwibi will release chapters of the
fan made movie every day for two weeks
the star-studded cast includes couples
joe jonas and sophie turner common and
Tiffany Haddish Neil Patrick Harris and
David Burtka Chris Pine and Annabelle
Wallis as well as Hugh Jackman Jennifer
Garner Elijah Wood Jon Hamm beanie
Feldstein Lucas hedges Jenna ortega jack
box
okay so it's not hosted by Joe and
Sophie right so it's an ensemble cast
are they the Princess Bride also I've
never I I've never seen it either movie
I saw the beginning of it and I saw
those little animals is that the one
where there's like those creatures I've
never seen it it's only it's before our
time and they terrified me oh really
these creatures that are like in some
sort of tunnel I think I'm thinking
about the right movie and I just
couldn't bring myself to watch such a
horror flick I've never seen it I Steve
Martin in it no that's father of the
bride a oh he's a - also what's the
Princess Bride
Princess Bride it's like um spooky a
little bit right no I don't think so
okay I found it to be quite spooky the
first time well you know I geez are
universal so like you could have had a
spooky experience and they it's a
fantasy adventure movie Oh comedy film
it's an American fantasy adventure
comedy film directed and co-produced by
Rob Reiner I feel like this is gonna be
one of those things people who are
listening are like you've never seen
like when we had um Women's Club what
was that Oh first why it's the First
Wives Club yeah well we just go back to
kwibi for a second um because quinny's
kind of testing the model like if we
throw enough celebrity talent at a wall
will it stick and so far it's not
sticking and I think largely due to the
fact that it's quarantine and most
people are still working from home even
if their cities are re-entering new
phases and people aren't necessarily
watching content on their phone they're
looking for TV to watch like bigger plot
bigger literally bigger screens and I've
seen a lot of articles kind of regarding
it as like a failure equip me yeah I
think it's also um it could still you
know bounce back it definitely was made
for people on the go and no one's going
anywhere nobody that's definitely a
setback but some of the content just
sounds exciting I mean this Joe Joan I
watch anything that would be Joe Jonas
and so if we turn her especially if
they're like in a scripted love story
like right it's so incredible so I'd
like that they're thinking outside the
box I think maybe eventually something
will stick yeah yeah Christie's Court is
coming back for Season two even though I
did watch it I didn't love it I just
thought like I didn't agree with some of
the judges rulings and it was a little
silly at points but Chris he was like
funny and cute and beautiful and I love
that she brought her sister and or her
mom is
bailiff there was a cute elements to it
even though I I had some notes okay
oh so time over love notes yeah okay
next story exciting interesting curious
where Honi stars debut new tag lines for
second half of season 12 The Real
Housewives of New York ladies are back
with new tag lines for the second half
of season 12 which is something that's
never been done before a midseason we're
getting a new tag lines and like a
change to the intro which makes sense
kind of on the heels of Tinsley's
departure but they always could have
cropped her out no it makes no sense it
was like they literally just could've
taken Tinsley out of the theme song I'm
like nobody would have really noticed
but they made it this whole press moment
there was like a people exclusive maybe
they're having ratings problems and they
wanted to like get some press I don't
know maybe they heard the cries of the
people absolutely hating this season's
taglines and gave us like just as
mediocre ones I don't know I kind of
like them and I love reading tag lines
is this from a housewife who to Ramona's
tag line so what if I'm self-involved
who else should I be involved with six
out of ten I'll give her a seven
I'll give er seven Lea's new tag line
I'll say sorry for what I've done but
never for Who I am
eight out of ten I'm gonna give her nine
Luann's
I rise above the drama and won't settle
for the lower-level seven six I
understand like it's a hark back to the
lower level but like whatever she's
trying to sell t-shirts Dorinda medley
zero I know it's so tight like a mint in
my mouth I can be a bit fresh like
actually it too I'm gonna give it a six
I liked it I thought it was clever and
like she can be fresh I don't like him
um Sonja Morgan I think coming in with
the win I'm no one's arm candy I'm the
whole bowl of sugar they're all like
making jokes based on this season you
know what I kind of like that like but
it wasn't that good of a season so for
like it's I mean it is a good season I
think maybe we haven't been enjoying it
maybe we're just like cynical cynical
and have been watching for so long and
just like Thai or an agency and really
missing Bethenny and I think it's like
the Bethenny sand within us it won't
allow us to like a show without her but
she chose to leave so yeah so you know
she wanted us to move on you know I know
that and I love Lea and I and I can't
ignore the fact that the show is not
near
is good of course it's not nearly as
good because there isn't that like
everyone's just getting away with
everything but there's no accountability
police yeah and like sometimes we go so
off the rails like I'm not even sure
what I'm watching and like and I feel
weird for watching it because it's like
this shouldn't be like entertainment
right um but I think overall it's been
it's been pretty good and I like that
these tag lines are so nice and very
relevant to the season at hand right and
I I like a spec I like a switch-up
I wonder if this is something they'll
continue to do it's just like a strange
new thing for Bravo to change up the tag
lines
I don't mind it gives me something to
talk about and you know new content to
watch I'm just like maybe it's the cynic
in me just like everything the Real
Housewives of New York do this season
like I'm just like man man man
everything is just giving me meb's yeah
I I'm not sure if it's you or if it's
them look is it the quarantine speaking
or does this show suck I don't know how
do you feel about Beverly Hills fabulous
so that's in quarantine to excellence at
its finest to see Brandi Glanville
posted something salacious on Instagram
yesterday I saw a headline she like
allegedly posted a picture of her in
Jenice like kissing on the lips
I said you try to make it very clear
that her and Denis had some sort of
affair where I think Denise is gonna
deny it in the coming episodes and
Brandi wanted to make it very clear and
you know what Brandi is a lot of things
but she doesn't really lies she's just
like ash pops sure but she never doesn't
tell the truth right but I think at a
certain point I mean we'll see what how
it plays out on the show but it's not
about whether it's true or false it's
whether like she should be sharing this
information increases private business
agreed fifth and final story ready for
it not if it's not a little business
it's not [ __ ] I'm not ready it's not a
little business what is it it's inside
Rob Kardashian's transformation inside
literally the greatest date ever
this is gonna this year is a total wash
except for Rob Kardashian being so happy
and healthy he takes care of himself and
works out he wants people to know that
he is doing well a source tells People
magazine but Rob Kardashian who attended
Khloe's 36th birthday over the weekend
Rob Kardashian is focused on being the
best version of himself though he has
purposefully remained private and out of
the spotlight in recent years a source
tells people that he has been
intentional in ten
shanell about improving his overall
well-being Rob is doing well he takes
care of himself works out and eats
better the source says about Rob for a
long time he was unhappy and embarrassed
about the way he looked but now he knows
he looks better he's comfortable enough
to be photographed he wants people to
know that he is doing well I mean I'm so
glad to hear he's doing well and I feel
like I mean it's not even about maybe
for him it's about how he looks you know
but for us like it's just so nice to see
him like smile smile and present and
wanting to take photos um I'm just
knowing that like within himself he's in
a good enough place to be doing that
yeah and you know I feel like Rob
Kardashian is a testament to like first
of all the fact that he really did
disappear like people think celebrities
have no privacy but like he did it like
he disappeared it is possible if he
wanted to and to I don't know but I just
find it so interesting that he had like
the whole world and his feet like
remember those seasons where it's like
Kris was like what he want to do like we
literally can make anything happen for
you he wants to start Arthur George and
he just really decided like that he
didn't really want any of this and I
find that so admirable in a lot of ways
while I would literally never do it I
find it very admirable and I just love
him and I have this like soft spot spot
in my heart for him because he just
those early seasons if I came in Adrian
and like he was such an integral part of
the family and I miss him but I'm like
so happy for him yeah and I I'm not sure
that he's come back or being in photos
includes him being on the show and and
changing his way of life from what he's
been doing for the past few years but
it's just for the fans like it's nice to
know that Rob's at the birthday Rob's
doing well the birthday looked amazing
sickening that is some sickening
Kardashian parties and soirees during
what's left of the queue um Khloe Kylie
did hurt Kendall Kylie we never talked
about how they did a club I did a collab
which is actually big news because she
was the only sister who hadn't done a
collab with Kylie yet and it was because
she had a makeup contract I think I said
that but like I wasn't sure that made
more sense than anything else yeah
and so I really liked that did you get
anything I didn't get anything cuz I
wasn't at a computer and I hadn't like
thought about what I would have wanted I
didn't really like investigate it but um
it looked like really great stuff now
that I'm ever gonna get this type of
information but I would be so curious to
see like some sales numbers for like
which sister collabs do the best I'm
sure that the Kendall and Kylie one was
up there it was really good they were
like new
products themselves oh cool it looks
really on brand on point like stuff that
you could really see yourself wearing as
well as Kendall and her party in her
basement was like sickening with this
the official word foo yeah party she
threw with a the movie theater it was so
sickening really like they're taking
quarantine parties to a whole new level
they are they are branded masks it was
so cute it was really cute same for
Khloe's birthday party I always love
when it's Chloe's birthday she's just a
light but it's a light you see it when
like everyone writes her birthday
captions like it really encompasses
everything that she is and I don't know
why I always like take stock of the fact
when it's her birthday like on Instagram
and the parties and the options and the
you know words of appreciation and it's
always nice to see I don't know it's
just always something that resonates
with me back to Rob really quickly I'm
so glad we're in this place and I know
we've been in like a lot of different
stages with Rob but I have to say my
least favorite stage was like when he
was technically on the outs with a lot
of his sisters because of the whole blac
Chyna thing like that made me really sad
I feel like he was like so depressed and
isolated for a while and when he like
was even more isolated from his family
like that was a really hard time for him
even though like he was welcoming a
child which is always a blessing I'm
just so happy like we are back together
like I can't explain like how that makes
me feel ya know it makes me feel really
fabulous I'm happy for everyone I feel
like the Kardashians are doing well
they're all right North just turned
seven she had a fabulous birthday party
in Wyoming which was like country themed
and it was just like so not her but I
loved it yeah I loved it too she's like
where's my Beverly Hills party for sure
but like she can do it all she's been
humbled yeah time for TV recap I'm dying
to talk about the athlete a documentary
in which for those who don't know is the
Larry Nasser USA Gymnastics documentary
about the awful atrocity atrocities that
were committed by Larry Nasser but of
course as with all these documentaries
you really see like how it was the
system that failed the girls not only
now Larry Nasser like Larry Nasser was
disgusting he would pretend that these
were like medical processes where he had
to like on gloved
I had to penetrate young girls without
gloves like it was so disgusting and he
was doing it all under the guise of
medicine and he's evil and he's horrible
but what the documentary really
is like how Maggie Nichols justice from
other [ __ ] Maggie Nichols she was
supposed to be on the 2016 team and she
was like at the trials she came in six
Gabby Douglas had come in seventh but
they gave the spot to Gabby Douglas but
then there's always three alternates and
she didn't get it so there was like 12
girls total Maggie Nichols was like six
and they totally like didn't even let
her go to the Olympics because when she
was at that ranch you know those two old
people Marta Karolyi and Bali I think
his name is they're like this older
couple from Romania and the documentary
really shows how they totally
transformed USA Gymnastics because they
were like big in Romania and America
wanted that and they came to America and
it's like gymnasts used to be like full
grown women yeah but in recent years
like most gymnasts are like in their
teens and 20s and that's largely because
of March and her husband they like they
said it was for like you know gymnasts
to be smaller and more compact and
aerodynamic but mostly was because they
could control younger girls more about
like their body and about their weight
and about their training and it goes
into like how abusive USA Gymnastics is
aside from Larry Nasser and the sexual
abuse like just abusive like these
ungodly hours like in Romania Mardan her
husband like used to physically like
beat the the girls like it was just so
crazy and so they have this ranch where
they go like for the training before the
Olympic Trials and that's where a lot of
Larry Nasser's indiscretions but in town
and happened to met Maggie Nichols and
she reported it immediately and she said
to Allie raisin and she was like Larry
nice or just and I was like yeah me too
and so Maggie reported that she did
everything right she reported it and
Steve penny who was the head of USA
Gymnastics was working with her family
with FBI involved were all over it for a
year nothing happened in Larry Nasser
went on assaulting more and more girls
like dozens of girls in the year since
he was already reported then thanks to
the Indiana Star a local newspaper
that's what those documentaries it's
always a local newspaper and just some
like good reporters just who stumble
into it and once they heard one story
there was another and another and
another and they got soap but if it
wasn't for Maggie Nichols in the
beginning they wouldn't have been able
to tie all these stories together but
the real crime here is [ __ ]
Steve penny who has daughters he is the
head of USA Gymnastics he allowed for
all of this to happen
there were so many of like alleged
issues of misconduct that were just
swept under the rug so many people just
ignoring it where it's like these girls
are bringing pride to our country like
they're working so [ __ ] hard to bring
home medals for our country like you
can't even protect them it was just so
disappointing how many victims there
were like there was a hearing and you
know the judge who was fabulous yeah at
the trial of Larry Nasser I want to say
her name was Judge Aqua Lina that sounds
familiar for mommy reported it she
allowed all the victims who wanted to to
show up and make witness testimonies to
plead to the judge like why he should
get the full sentence and say something
tellurian asked her if she wanted and
they just had so much footage and they
interviewed for the documentary like the
lead investigator and the a DA and there
were two women and they were like
literally just talking about the witness
testimonies and they were like both
crying and it was like so powerful and
it was just such a well-done documentary
it's just like such an upsetting story
because what you find out at the end
which is classic documentary the FBI
like quote-unquote investigated it and
now the FBI isn't means being
investigated for how they handled the
investigation but it's like once again
at the FBI what you take from every
documentary on Netflix whether it's
trials of Gabriel Fernandez Jeffrey
Epstein Jeffrey Epstein Wake Waco
athlete day like the FBI knows about
everything and does nothing about and
it's so disappointing and there's no
accountability because they're the FBI
but that's what I learned from athlete a
justice for [ __ ] Maggie Nichols who
didn't give up on her dreams of
gymnastics even though it was literally
just torturous for her now she's at
Oklahoma University and she's back to
back n-c-double-a champion she's like
it's like so fun they did so much
gymnastics footage in the documentary
which I loved and then footage of her
she won in 2017 and defended her title
in 2018 and like she was just like doing
the gymnastics but like this girl went
to the Olympics like honestly it looked
so easy for her when she was on the
floor at the NCAA tournament it was just
kind of funny but she is the real hero
like justice for her yeah Wow okay I'm
gonna watch it that sounds easy I just
boiled it yeah but no but it's still an
important story and Larry Nasser got the
full sentence back-to-back 60-year
sentences by you ugly like you know he's
like people who just heard
face like you just poof cringe and you
know what was so [ __ ] up about the
whole thing is that like all the girls
were just like when they were in
training they were just like abused so
badly and they like wouldn't let them
eat and they would call them fat and
Larry Nasser used to like sneak them
snacks and like leave them under their
pillows so like they all really trusted
him before and like that's why so many
girls I mean it was literally hundreds
of girls and it took them a while to
speak up because they like literally
didn't even know what was happening to
them because to them like Larry was
their friend like he really protected
them and like when they were injured and
the coaches were just like berating them
like he was the one helping them and
saving them and giving them snacks and
it was just like so [ __ ] up yeah it
was a really good documentary
geez [ __ ] Larry Nasser and Steve penny
and all the people who knew about the
abuse they were just the sheer amount of
people who knew about it they had like
this whole timeline like that's what's
so disturbing
yeah like and women too they knew and
did nothing that's so disturbing yeah
justice her Maggie Nichols really great
documentary on Netflix highly recommend
it um and I said it I guess that is it
um yeah we have one more patreon episode
coming out today yeah a very exciting
patreon.com slash the morning toast if
you want more content from us a little
behind the scenes and that's all she
broke make sure you are watching and
ordering my comedy special disgraced
Queen all the info will be on my
Instagram and we thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast
millennial Morning Show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available podcasts and we're
podcast can be found so Spotify iTunes
stitcher Public Radio iearnt radio cast
box all the places so wherever you
listen to podcast find out somewhere in
toasting the five star review about a
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
love you guys so much movie about the
sable see you for hump day bye